[Musica]
pensiamo per un attimo a tutte le
emozioni che l'essere umano in grado di
provare felicità rabbia gioia dolore
paura eccitazione ansia passione
prendiamo tutte queste emozioni e
condensiamo le in un unico sport
questo è quello che si prova ogni volta
che si indossa il casco e si scende in
pista per una gara e questa me la
ricordo come se fosse ieri un anno e
mezzo fa
la prima gara in moto della mia vita in
griglia di partenza
dentro il casco piangevo dall'emozione
ed erano emozioni che hanno sempre
sognato di provare sin da bambino
sognavo di fare il pilota un giorno e
siamo stati tutti quanti bambini
sappiamo benissimo che sin da quando si
è piccoli siano dei sogni
c'è chi sogna di fare l'esploratore
spaziale chi sogna di fare il maestro
jedi chi sogna di fare l'allenatore di
pokémon chi sogna di fare il pilota
e voi vi direte beh il migliorano
l'unico sogno forse un po sensazione tra
tutti questi ecco il problema è che chi
lavora nel mondo dei motori forse lo sa
per fare il pilota serve un sacco di
soldi devi essere ricco mia mamma faceva
l'impiegata mio papà al pizzaiolo forse
era meglio fare l'allenatore di pokémon
ma allora ci si chiede come ho fatto a
passare da un bambino con un sogno più
grande di lui a un ragazzo che ha 29
anni ha fatto di quel sogno il suo
lavoro
il vero problema della vita che non
esiste un manuale d'uso
noi andiamo in un negozio comprare un
elettrodomestico non so se un frullatore
torniamo a casa non montiamo attacchiamo
la spina lo schiacciamo e non parte
allora quel punto cosa facciamo
prendiamo in mano alle istruzioni
vediamo dove abbiamo sbagliato e lo
facciamo funzionare e per la vita
noi nasciamo con dei sogni delle idee e
dei progetti delle ambizioni
lasciamo con gli strumenti per
realizzare questi sogni delle gambe
traccia occhi bocca e orecchie un
cervello ma nessuno che ci spiega come
fare se un manuale d'uso e uno dice
vabbè allora puoi scrivere un manuale di
istruzioni così hai risolto il problema
dell'umanità della vita
il problema è che dovremmo fare 8
miliardi di manuali perché quello che
sogno io non è la stessa cosa che sogna
lui gli strumenti che ho io non sono gli
stessi che a lei capite dunque che nel
momento in cui uno viene al mondo non
solo deve capire che cosa vuole fare da
grande ma soprattutto deve capire come
arrivare a farlo
ognuno di noi ognuno di noi deve trovare
la propria strada e mi hanno colpito
molto due frasi che ho letto su google
con un po di ricerche la prima una
ricerca fatta dalla rivista
businessinsider chi dice che il 65 per
cento dei bambini che inizia la prima
elementare farà un lavoro che non esiste
quando io in prima elementare i social
non esistevano e io oggi lavoro sui
social e l'altra frase che mi ha colpito
molto e che non è la specie più forte o
la più intelligente a sopravvivere ma
quella che si adatta meglio al
cambiamento
analizzando dunque questo mio percorso
che mi ha portato dall aver realizzato
un sogno irrealizzabile ho cercato di
capire quali fossero state le chiavi di
questo successo laddove ricordiamoci che
è successo del tutto soggettivo per me è
successo e correre in moto per altri il
successo e fare una famiglia e ed è
proprio quello di cui vi voglio parlare
oggi in questo talk raccontandovi la mia
storia e facendomi capire un metodo che
ho sviluppato per arrivare a realizzare
i propri sogni
avevo 16 anni quando avete presente quei
giorni da ragazzini in cui siamo lì sul
divano abbiamo la playstation la tv
un libro e non abbiamo voglia di fare
niente si sta così bene la sul divano
squilla il telefono mi chiamano gli
amici dicono oh bella viene giocare da
noi ma ne voglia era pari a zero
stavo così bene su quel divano ma quel
giorno non ho detto di no ma ho detto di
sì sono uscito controvoglia arrivo a
casa loro e trovo lì per terra un
volante buttato lì per terra per
computer
loro mi guarda e mi dicono lo vuoi
possiamo approfittare via no preso
tornato a casa l'ho montato subito sul
mio computer con monitor a tubo catodico
processore pentium ii da 95 e ho
iniziato a giocare videogame di auto e
in quel momento ho capito perché
volevano buttare col volante
faceva veramente schifo l'avranno pagato
20 euro a un mercatino dell'usato e
funzionava anche male però mi divertivo
come un pazzo
passavo le giornate a giocare videogame
di auto e me la cavavo anche bene e così
a quel punto ho detto basta
devo fare il pilota ho trovato il mio
lavoro così mi sono messo a cercare su
google come diventare piloti ho
conosciuto un ex pilota di formula 3000
ci si è messi lì a chattare su msn
messenger perché all'epoca si sa ma
quello è la prima domanda che mi ha
fatto è quanti soldi hai ci sarà da
pagare un'iscrizione come la scuola
calcio dato in tasca velato salvadanaio
a 250 euro e lui scoppiato a ridere ma
guarda una stagione costa 100.000 euro
non so dove vuoi andare o sei ricco o
non corri
non è facile da mandare giù all'inizio
però devi scontrarti con la realtà mondo
funziona così però mi ha detto se tu hai
un volante e un computer puoi giocare
alle gare che facciamo noi sul
simulatore di guida
il primo premio un test su una vera auto
da corsa
ovviamente non ha anche fatto in tempo a
finire la frase che jarolim allenavo è
iniziato a correre da qualche giorno
questo mio nuovo amico mi dice guarda 6
montare video ci piacerebbe che qualcuno
facesse i video delle gare che facciamo
sul simulatore di guida non avevo la più
pallida idea di come si montasse un
video però quel giorno non dissi di no
ma dissi di sì mi misi su youtube
inizia a cercare tutorial su come
montare video guardavo come li facevano
in tv e cercavo di fare qualcosa di
simile ed era veramente imbarazzante
perché io ero lì chiuso nella mia
cameretta immaginatevi un sedicenne
brufoloso con l'apparecchio senza
neanche una fidanzata con un microfono
preso 20 euro nel supermercato sfigato
che urla e sputacchia dentro un
microfono pensando di essere guido meda
e mi prendevano in giro tutti quanti per
questa cosa fare mi divertivo ed ero
felice e soprattutto stavo imparando un
nuovo mestiere
la paga per quel lavoretto fu un
computer nuovo una nuova postazione più
professionale
passai settimane per settimane mesi ad
allenarmi un'estate intera chiuso in
casa ad allenarmi al simulatore e l'anno
dopo vinse il primo premio un test su
una vera auto da corsa con la mia
passione mi aveva portato dentro mio
sogno
pensavo di averlo realizzato ed era
andato forte quel giorno me l'ero cavata
bene così vado dal team manager finita
la stessa
signori dico allora come sono andato il
team ha parlato molto bene devo dire che
sei stato bravo
la prima volta che vidi questa macchina
non ci aspettavamo questo risultato io
sceglierò che con gola a voi mi vedevo
già scuderia ferrari alberto nasca nuovo
pilota 2019 spostati leclerc e team
manager mi dice guarda dato che sei così
bravo
l'anno prossimo pensiamo di chiederti
solo 50mila euro io ancora e 150 euro
del salvadanaio venne però mi dice
guarda
sappiamo che non c'è in europa dato che
ti piace correre sei bravo a fare video
potresti venire a fare i video delle
nostre giornate in pista non ti paghiamo
ma ti facciamo provare l'auto da corsa
loro stavano varese io stavo torino dire
di sì significava dato che devo essere
alle 6 del mattino a varese e non aveva
una macchina non ho i soldi per comprare
una macchina significa prendere il treno
di mezzanotte a torino andrea milano
arrivare a 2 di notte 2004 alla stazione
prende il treno per andare a varese
andare allora è tutto il giorno per
farmi dieci minuti su questa macchina
corso tornare a casa
rinuncia il sabato sera con gli amici
alle uscite alle fidanzate alla
discoteca non dissi di no ma dissi di sì
e quella mentre pendenza sopressata
punto che poi mi offrendo anche un
lavoretto retribuito e inizia a
guadagnare nei primi soldini gli anni
passarono e si presentò un occasione un
talent show per aspiranti piloti per
farti prendere dovevi fare un video che
li convincesse a prenderti la mia
esperienza nel montaggio video che in
quegli anni era sembrato una cosa fine a
se stessa mi permise di realizzare un
video molto divertente con il quale mi
presero e nel video che non sa che
vestito da donna impersonando mia madre
disperata perché suo figlio so io
giocavo tutti i giorni videogame e
quindi prendete mio figlio vi prego
l'esperienza accumulata sui simulatori
di guida e in quelle prove sulle auto da
corsa mi permise di vincere il primo
premio il mio conto in banca era passato
da 150 euro che era sempre lì perché non
c'erano i soldi nel far niente quindi
quelli a 15 mila euro
avevo tra le mani un'occasione d'oro
mi ero appena laureato a casa al
rapporto alla disastrosa
ero depresso faceva una vita schifosa
d'inferno avevo degli amici milano
sapevo fare un lavoro avevo delle
conoscenze nel motorsport
così ho deciso di mollare
tutto trasferirmi a milano e prendere i
video che facevo sui simulatori di guida
e proporli nella realtà e iniziai così
ad andare a bussare a tutte le porte
organizzatori prove libere campionati
piloti team e scuderie per proporre i
miei servizi video
questa era la mia vita passavo le
giornate davanti a un computer a montare
video mangiando minestrine perché quello
mi potevo permettere
per ora felice faceva un lavoro nel
mondo di motori era un passo verso il
motorsport sperando che qualcosa potesse
succedere il vero problema è che ero
entrato in un loop di giorno a casa
montavo i video il giorno dopo in pista
girare video a casa a montare video in
pista girare video caso montare video in
pista genere video erano lavoro bell ora
figo proprio quattro anni ho fatto la
stessa cosa e non si muoveva nulla
intorno a me
nessuna speranza di poter diventare
pilota a quel punto capì che bisognava
uscire da questa routine è un giorno
arrivò alla mia fidanzata
cioè la fidanzata dell'epoca adesso la
mia ex all'epoca ci amavamo adesso
purtroppo finita come è finita
arrivai vidi se voglio fare un corso di
teatro ma compagni e dico ci aiuterà il
pilota che chi manifesta lì col teschio
estero non essere non dissi di no però
disse di sì e inizia il corso di teatro
che non c'entra nulla col fare il pilota
però mi divertivo nel 2016
qualche anno dopo un giorno in cui non
avevo nulla da fare penso l'unico degli
ultimi sei anni
mi misi ii e inizia a smistare il
materiale video e vi di questa che per
chi se ne intende di motori forse
capisce chi non se ne intende gliela
spiego questo pilota sta per cadere allo
sterzo chiudo non ha più grip davanti
questo pilota è riuscito a salvare la
moto da una caduta certa è fatto una
manovra incredibile e quando ho visto
quella manovra
ho sentito il bisogno di raccontarla
tutti tutti dovevano sapere quello che
era riuscito a fare questo pilota così
missili nella mia cameretta e gira une
vidéo numero anche fatto la barba non un
arabo scena e l'esperienza del montaggio
video unita all'esperienza nel mondo dei
motori unita all'esperienza nel teatro
mi ha permesso di realizzare un video
che fu visto da 120 mila persone
quel video era diventato virale mi era
esplosa una bomba tra le mani
e fu il colpito wow ne vuoi fare un
altro ne fece un altro poi due poi
cinque poi dieci poi 20 poi 50 nel giro
di un anno arriva ad avere 50 mila
persone che guardavano i miei video nel
giro di due anni e mezzo queste persone
erano inventate 420.000 e con quella
visibilità alle aziende iniziarono a
contattarmi per propormi moto caschi
tute guanti sponsor budget denaro e in
quel modo totalmente imprevisto ero
riuscito a realizzare finalmente il mio
sogno di correre e fermiamoci per un
attimo a pensare
e stato un percorso incredibile questo
un percorso talmente assurdo che se uno
si fosse messo lì si fosse seduto che
non avrebbe potuto progettare niente del
genere è partito tutto da un giorno in
cui sono uscito controvoglia sono andato
a casa di amici a 16 anni
il fatto è che per aver realizzato
questo sogno non ho fatto in realtà
niente di speciale non ho nessun talento
per carità ha vinto qualche gara me la
cavo bene ma ci sono piloti molto forti
molto mille volte più forti di me non ho
non sono un genio non ho inventato una
nuova formula o semplicemente l'unica
cosa che ho fatto è stata unire i
puntini e se noi prendiamo un foglio
bianco e qualcuno ci dice fai un disegno
viene fuori una creata pochi poi appeso
c'è la capacità di segnare ma se abbiamo
dei puntini se abbiamo una traccia da
seguire siamo tutti bravi a disegnare
questo dunque mi ha fatto capire
qualcosa che è quello che vi voglio
raccontare in questo talk che nessuno di
noi è in grado di realizzare un sogno
partendo da zero da un foglio bianco e
progettando un percorso quello che noi
dobbiamo fare in quel foglio andare a
mettere dei puntini una volta che sono
quei puntini e unirli è come si creano
questi puntini ho scoperto che questi
puntini si creano nel momento in cui noi
usciamo dalla nostra routine nel momento
in cui noi facciamo qualcosa di diverso
dal solito ci piace il jazz
andiamo ad ascoltare un concerto metal
ci piace il golf tranquillo calmo vedere
un incontro di wrestling dove si
picchiano fino alla morte
quel giorno non c'è nessuno dei nostri
amici che vuoi uscire prendiamo andiamo
a una mostra di cui non ce ne può fregar
di meno perché nel momento in cui
facciamo qualcosa di diverso nel momento
in cui siamo dalla nostra zona di
confort che si presentano le occasioni
le occasioni che poi diventano quei
puntini che una volta che andremo a
unire ci si presenterà davanti il
disegno a questo punto gli errori che si
fanno possono essere quelli di pensare
che uscirà dalla comfort jonsi a
prendere un aereo andare dall'altra
parte del mondo mollare famiglia lavoro
amici casa e cambiare vita
quello non è uscire dalla confusione
quando farò un salto nel buio andare
nella zona di terrore sia con forza non
significa fare ogni giorno qualcosa di
piccolo ma diverso da ciò che siamo
abituati a fare
l'altro grosso errore che si fa in
questi casi quello di attribuire queste
occasioni il successo i buoni risultati
alla fortuna fortuna quando tu prendi un
dado lo lanci una volta ed esce 6 quella
fortuna quella che chiamiamo botta di
culo ma se tu quel da te lo prendi lo
lanci cento volte quante volte ti esce 6
questa è una differenza veramente
importante e l'altra grande differenza
che voi sentendo questo racconto che è
stato qualcosa incredibile perché se io
non fossi uscito quel giorno
controvoglia e non avessi preso col
volante se non avessi cercato su google
come diventare piloti se non avessi
detto di sì a imparare un nuovo lavoro
se non avessi detto di sì a prendere un
treno 2004 amministrazione
se non avessi detto di sì a fare un
corso di teatro come che cosa cavolo me
ne frega il teatro tutto questo non
sarebbe successo
il fatto che io gli ho raccontato le
occasioni che sono andate bene ma non vi
ho raccontato quelle che non hanno
portato a nulla di uscite contro
vogliano fatte centinaia ma solo una è
stata quella fondamentale di persone non
conosciute 10.000 ma solo tre o quattro
sono state quelle fondamentali di video
hanno montato in mille ma solo uno è
stato quello fondamentale la cosa è
credibile è che nel momento in cui ci si
presenta un'occasione e noi andiamo a
mettere un puntino su quel foglio bianco
non ce ne renderemo conto in quel
momento non capiremo che abbiamo davanti
un'occasione che andrà a comporre un
disegno importante per la nostra vita
lo capiremo magari ad anni di distanza
quell'uscita controvoglia che ho fatto a
16 anni
quel giorno mi è sembrata inutile fine a
se stessa
cinque anni dopo mi era sembrata inutile
soltanto oggi dopo 13 anni ho capito che
quello è stato il giorno più importante
della mia vita
[Applauso]
[Musica]